well
another thought that i had too is we
have a lot of moments in history
as far as like oh yeah not even the
viral [ __ ] but i'm getting tagged and
[ __ ]
where it's like i'm talking about like
bro we did we did the nipsy
passing dude that was crazy because that
was i was on the air sundays
check this out the sunday nipsey died
nifty died on a sunday kobe died on a
sunday yep that i was on the air for
both of those yep
then you came into my shift and we ended
up doing the nipsy thing
yep that was rough rough bro i think
that was probably the roughest uh
you know obviously kobe dine was rough
but we knew nip you know uh
that was the roughest [ __ ] was to do
that radio show
that was rough and all i could think
about
and then we also you knew
because we were on almost right away
yeah and you i think you
had information that it wasn't looking
good but while we were on the air we
couldn't
divulge that yeah i couldn't talk about
it yeah so we were waiting for it to
come down that it was official that he
passed
and then yeah one of my homies one of my
homies one of my street homies hit me
was like yes it's
it's a rap bro like i just want you to
be the first to know because you know
that he [ __ ] with you tough so
i was like what like so then um doc hit
me and was like yo you mind going to the
station i'm like bro
i don't know what to say right and he
was like just be honest
just talk so i went up there and came up
there we did the show
that was like one of them and all i
could think about is
is those old school radio moments where
i remember being
i remember being at i remember being on
my way to school
when 9 11 happened yeah yeah and i
remember big boy being on the air that
morning
right and he just stayed on the air like
the whole time and he was just like yo
if you go outside and look up there's no
planes in the sky in the country
and i was like i remember i literally
remember that and i was like this is one
of them things where people are going to
be remembering this [ __ ]
and it it and i thought about this after
the fact obviously i'm not thinking
about that while we're doing the show
but i'm thinking about this after the
fact like people have been with us for
moments
that probably they're gonna remember for
the rest of their life and that [ __ ] is
that's the [ __ ] to me that is like yeah
it's crazy that's fire
kobe's death was so big in in the world
but i don't feel like it the impact
it felt like here i feel like nipsy [ __ ]
felt
way crazy well it was it because i think
what happened was
like uh nemesis was murdered yeah
i think it's that like colby's death was
horrible and tragic
of course it was horrible an accident
yeah but the way nipsey died man
we we saw it ever in broad daylight like
it was just a
complete blazing act of like murder you
know what i'm saying so it's like
that to me is like something because and
also you gotta look at what he or he
what he represented
yeah it's not even what he did or who he
was nobody give a [ __ ]
what you represent is like everything
and
if you represent hope you represent
community you represent
you know aspiration entrepreneurship
giving back whatever it is you represent
and then some and then you that that
type of thing happened to you where it
happened to them i think it quit
it makes everybody question their own
mortality and i think that's what
that's that [ __ ] that shakes everybody
yeah that was rough that one the kobe sh
i was numb for the kobe [ __ ] to be
honest
i didn't even process it till like a
month later yeah the kobe [ __ ]
i was really really sad and i never even
[ __ ] with kobe when he was like i was
i'm a i don't [ __ ] with the lakers i
[ __ ] with him now cause lebron's on
there
but growing up i hated kobe right but i
like didn't hate him in like a
real way i just as a sports fan as a
sportsman
but when he died i was like [ __ ] like
this was like a part of my life facts
like i watched this guy play
basketball's entire career
like and now this will gone like
you never know you never know bro that's
that's one of them things to me even
even when pop smoke got murdered like it
was it's like different things that like
i never thought would be a part of my
radio career yo the fact that we lost
pop smoke x juice world
yup nipsey kobe mac miller
yep all while we were doing the show
yep it's insane i feel like we're
forgetting people
oh for sure a lot of people have been
passing man we for sure forgetting
people but i'm just saying though
that i've never thought about like oh
this is going to be a part of my radio
journey
yeah cause even with pop smoke like pop
smoke like you know he did a lot of
interviews but he didn't do that many
nah he didn't do a lot of interviews he
didn't do a lot so it's like yo we have
like
you know we talked to him really early
on and he was cool as [ __ ] like he was
always super nice super cool
and he had just so much uh just so much
like more to give
and then also if you look at the other
side of the spectrum when we had
ymw mellie on he went to jail the next
day or the day after we did the last
interview the last interview before he
got locked up yep
yeah it's crazy man it's a lot of [ __ ]
dawg i think um
one of my favorites though
one of my favorites probably ever
was t-pain oh the t-pain interview is a
legendary love
t-pain bro he's so yeah we talking for
like an hour at least
i love t-pain he's now that t-pain
interview is a movie he's so
entertaining he's so
honest and funny and we got drunk drunk
whenever we were taking shots
yeah you did and i like 50 cent 50 was
dope i love how
honest 50 is ross was dope well we've
had some good ones
i mean the haiti baby freestyle went
crazy bro the haiti baby freestyle bro
yeah you had them on your show i had
them on mine after the fact and i love
the fact that he like he leans into that
like that's part of my legacy
that's the biggest part of his legacy at
this point that's the homie but yeah i
mean right now like with it
he's nothing he's done it's ever been
bigger than that yeah that [ __ ] had
rihanna tweeting and chrissy teigen
tweeting about him and mcmill posted him
like that shit's insane
facts [ __ ] haiti baby shout out to
stockton man